vous souhaitiez fermé arrêté 14
réacteurs nucléaires aujourd'hui vous
annoncer que vous voulez en construire
14 vous avez totalement changer d'amis
pas du tout
concrètement 14 réacteurs de 900
mégawatts seront arrêtées d'ici à 2035
on va du nouveau utilisé charbon
pourquoi parce qu'en fait on a des
centrales nucléaires qui sont à l'arrêt
ce mouvement commencera avec l'arrêt
définitif des deux réacteurs de
fessenheim on a même fermer une centrale
fessenheim trop souvent on continue à
ouvrir de nouvelles centrales à charbon
allumé charbon pour éviter de la côte
c'est ce que vient de décider le
gouvernement qui s'apprêtait en fait à
faire voter un décret autorisant un
recours accru aux centrales à charbon
pour passer l'hiver la cohérence d'une
stratégie européenne de transition ce
serait que tous les pays qui ont encore
de nombreuses centrales à charbon les
fermes fondement a donc autorisé le
recours au charbon pour produire de
l'électricité mais c'était ça ou la
panne ont totalement changé d'avis pas
du tout